bonsoir aulas peut-on croire cessez le
feu avec cette réunion du cabinet de
sécurité israélien ce soir quelles sont
les dernières informations dont vous
disposez le cabinet de sécurité
israélien se rencontrent ce soir comme
vous l'avait dit et ils vont voter sur
le soutien ou bien je sème la terreur
d'après les informations disponibles il
y a de soutien pour ce fossé le feu
devrait intervenir au cours des 24
prochaines heures on avons pas d
informations déterminantes quant à leur
était d'application du cessez le feu
d'après les récentes informations cela
pourrait intervenir en soirée au cabinet
de sécurité devrait voter en faveur de
ce cessez le feu
les etats-unis ont-ils dit que les
signes sur le terrain et du hamas et
israël sont très encourageants et
vis-à-vis de ceux ci c'est le fait joe
biden le président américain est en
contact constant avec le président
égyptien ou issus sicié qui a des
contacts avec israël tout comme avec le
hamas
et ils ont conçu ensemble ce cessez le
feu
tout comme lors de conflits précédents
il restera des problèmes en suspens par
exemple le hamas souhaite aucune
présence israélienne sur le territoire
du hamas qu'israël ne sera pas d'accord
il n'ya pas non plus de consensus sur ce
qui va arriver à cheikh jarrah ce
quartier à israël en israël à jérusalem
prêté à la racine de la violence selon
certains des palestiniens risquent
d'être expulsés de chez eux et on n'a
toujours pas de réponse sans doute
probable qu'il y aura une flambée de
violences des deux parties elle
sur le teint s'attend donc à une
nouvelle nuit de roquettes à gaza il est
certain qu'on s'attend à des nouvelles
frappes israéliennes avant un cessez le
feu nous avons déjà observé cela lors de
la dernière guerre il ya sept ans et une
flambée de violence sur les terrains
juste avant le cessez le feu alors voilà
sur le terrain justement près de
quelques heures de répit dans la bande
de gaza cet après midi les frappes se
sont même intensifiées
quelques heures plus tard dans l'après
midi effectivement une intensification
du côté gazaoui eu beaucoup de frappes
israël tente d'éloigner autant que
possible ce qu'elle appelle
l'infrastructure terroriste du hamas
israël et le hamas
vont ils tirer parti des dernières
heures avant le cessez-le-feu pour
essayer d'atteindre leurs objectifs
respectifs
c'est à dire pour hamas d'attaquer
autant d'endroits que possible en israël
et pour israël de frapper autant que
possible les installations du hamas sur
le terrain continue les frappes
dans le même temps bien sûr le bilan est
à très élevé à gaza et continue à
augmenter plus de 200 palestiniens ont
été tués du côté israélien
d'après l'armée israélienne aujourd'hui
ce sont quatre vingt dix neuf roquettes
ont été tirées vers le centre d'israël
donc effectivement pas de relâchement
d'un côté ou de l'autre
la dernière guerre entre hamas israël
remonte à 2014
deux heures après le cessez le feu
israélien ont été tués et l'un d'eux
avait été kidnappé et ramené à gaza on
pense qu'il est mort mais les familles
sont très actives et teese qui ne peut
pas y avoir de cessez le feu sans un
retour de soldats ou le retour en tout
cas de
sa dépouille un autre soldat à gaza ils
sont également morts donc il ya beaucoup
de discussions afin de savoir si le
retour de celle de soldats sera un quart
incorporés dans les négociations pour un
cessez le feu
la plupart des israéliens souhaitent la
paix mais beaucoup d'israéliens pense
qu'il s'agit également d'une occasion
pour israël de détruire autant plus
possible les infrastructures du hamas
certains disent rien disent donc qu'il
est dommage que le cessez le feu
interviennent maintenant et non pas dans
quelques jours je j'ai également demandé
à mes collègues à gaza et ils disent que
hamas souhaite depuis plusieurs jours un
cessez-le-feu et que c'est israël qu'il
souhaitait continuer les hostilités
situation humanitaire à gaza
c'est que l'intense mis les
interrogations et monétaire est prêt
grave il ya des pénuries de médicaments
de docteurs et pénurie de logements les
habitants se retrouvent dans des écoles
des refuges
il devra y avoir beaucoup de
reconstruction à gaza notamment pour les
personnes qui ont perdu leur logement au
cours des deux dernières semaines de
combats merci paul à slayer journalistes
pour rt internationale en direct de tel
aviv merci d'avoir été avec nous